great to talk with all three of you
uh i have a ton of questions but i do
have to ask mr dinero a quick question
first just because
i've always wanted to know as a big fan
of a bronx tale
and the extremely underrated good
shepherd i've always wondered
if you came close to directing something
else well i wanted to do a sequel to
good shepherd and uh
you know making a movie is like
it's an uphill battle that's okay and i
had a i was working with eric roth on it
the
the the writer of the for the good
shepherd
and i it um it just never
fully happened um we just never got it
going i i that was the only thing i was
really interested i never thought of
myself directing more than
five movies if ever in my lifetime if i
find something that i really
feel very strongly about and feel i can
do something with i would uh
would do it and and even a sequel to the
good shepherd
if someone came along and said look i
have this money that i don't know what
to do with
and i want to give it to you to make the
movie i'll say okay i'll make it
i actually really love that movie and
for uh for you guys who maybe have not
seen it yet um i would really recommend
watching it
matt damon is excellent angelina jolie
it's quite good
um jumping into now other things uh
for laura and oakley i am curious um how
many of your friends and family
said they needed to visit you while
filming this when they found out
uh dinero was going to be in it um
i don't know about oaks but my family
definitely won
my family actually didn't i just had um
my manager at one point of uh visit me
while filming
i think everyone wanted to and i think
also everyone was super intimidated by
it everyone was like
oh my god this cast is insane do i even
want to meet them this is crazy
i i think my just my my close family my
my sister at one point my my brother and
my
i think my dad was with me it would have
been my mom also came
so that that was it but uh yeah it's
always nice to have family visit on set
no matter what it is or what for and
yeah it's always nice
uh i would imagine this film is gonna
sell an awful lot of trampolines
so i am curious about oakley and robert
if you've gotten in
on any sort of residuals on the
trampoline industry
no i wish i had gotten the idea
earlier from you and i would have looked
that trampoline stuff looked like it was
a blast to film uh was it
i had a good time it was fun
definitely i i i would say the same
thing i think it was a lot of fun and
the cast on on set those days were
definitely
um you know stacked and it was it was
cool to have everybody all in one place
um you know doing those scenes and and
having fun while doing it i had a good
time with with everybody uh
seeing chris walken and and cheech marin
and
it was just fun to watch them do what
they were doing the whole thing with the
kids
it was a lot of fun uh laura i don't
think a lot of people realize
that you were in superbad when you were
much younger
uh i was right and i am very curious
when did you realize what movie you were
really a part of
and how many years before you could see
it okay
so great question i have to say i was
always raised um
as a child actor i was always raised to
read the script beforehand so i was 11
and i read the script and i was
horrified i was truly like
is this how guys talk this is disgusting
you know i knew what i was looking at um
and the director
told me that the picture i was looking
at was
two guys fighting um but i knew what i
was supposed to be looking at
uh and i didn't see the movie till years
later and when i finally did i
thought it was the funniest movie i
thought it was so so funny
so i for me i did not see
the movie um at that age and when i was
reading that script
but later it was it it was an awesome
movie they did a great job
oh it's fantastic yeah i can't believe a
part of it
right now totally uh i would imagine i
am something i've always wondered
um for for all three of you uh i would
imagine there's a day that you're
stepping on set that you're nervous
about something whether it be a line of
dialogue
whether it be a stunt whether it be you
know it could be anything
i'm curious if you guys could each share
um a day that you were really
nervous about filming something and why
sometimes there's
uh at least as a as a younger actor and
obviously during this time as well um
you know working on set you also or
if it's during the school year doing
school as well so that's
something you have to balance and that
can be difficult when it comes down to
like you know switching gears from
um doing your school on set and then
also you know going to film
um and i think sometimes that switching
of gears can be a little bit difficult
and can
bring about some nerves but that's
that's the the main thing that's ever
even
uh you know made me nervous while being
on set that's
at least for me i went into another film
right away that was very very different
it was
a drama it was rated r and
i actually got the opportunity to
produce it as well um
and one scene in particular it's based
on a book and it was my favorite scene
in the book
where the sister the character i play
find something out and it causes her to
have this emotional breakdown
um i truly like i cried reading it in
the book and the day of the scene we
were filming it the author was there
so i was already nervous about doing
justice to the scene but having the
author there as well was like
really really nerve-wracking um but i
talked to the director beforehand and
you know we kind of talked about
what this set was going to be like like
kind of what i needed as an actor
for me to get that scene um
and i felt really happy with the work
afterwards but i was
nervous like crazy that day
i have a couple of stories but they're
too too complicated for this
interview another time if you have a
more time or we do it one-on-one you
would understand it as soon as i told
you but um
i've had that feeling though of feeling
oh my god after all these years of
um anxiety um
going to the set one time going to the
set when i had
my young kids in the car jumping all
around
um the dog in the back running and
just total chaos and trying to keep my
concentration on what i was about to do
and not even sure how i was gonna do it
when i got there because of the
situation the way it was presented to me
at last minute
so that's as much as i'll go into but it
was uh can you at least say
can you say what movie it was i can't
even do that now i mean maybe one day
late
but i yeah it was um no problem
no situation but but i had the feeling
was you know i hadn't had that feeling
in
in since i was a young actor and i've
rarely had that feeling but
this was one time when i was older when
i
i was put in a situation that i that i
was nervous about i'm already out of
time with you guys i'm just going to say
congrats and i really do hope you get
money from the
trampolines thank you thank you have a
great day